CONSERVATIVE LAWYER GEORGE ,
CONWAY, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WAITING WITH US LOOK, THESE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE HEARINGS
SET TO BEGIN THURSDAY NIGHT.
YOU SAID BEFORE, RIGHT HERE ON
CNN, THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T NEED
TO SHOW ANY NEW BOMBSHELLS IN
ORDER TO MAKE THEIR CASE FOR
CONSPIRACY.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU HOPING TO LEARN
FROM THESE HEARINGS?
>> WELL, I'M HOPING TO LEARN,
WHAT THE REST OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC, MORE OF THE DETAILS OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
WE'RE HEARING A LOT OF THIS
STUFF KIND OF THIRD HAND, NOT
FROM DIRECTLY FROM WITNESS
DEPOSITIONS, WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME OF THE WITNESSES, SOME OF
THE VIDEO FROM THE WITNESSES.
I THINK IT WILL BE, YOU KNOW, IF
IT'S DONE CORRECTLY AND I HAVE
EVERY REASON TO BELIEVE IT WILL
BE DONE CORRECTLY IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE VERY DRAMATIC TO SEE
THE PEOPLE, WHO, FOR EXAMPLE,
WORK FOR MIKE PENCE TALK ABOUT
THE PRESSURE DONALD TRUMP PUT ON
MIKE PENCE TO SEE WITNESSES LIKE
MIKE LUDIG GO ON THE STATE AND
TALK ABOUT THE ADVICE HE GAVE
VICE-PRESIDENT PENCE AND ALSO
HEAR MORE DIRECT EVIDENCE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th AT
THE CAPITOL.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF THINGS WE
CAN HEAR, BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, AS I'VE SAID, WE
ALREADY HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
CONCLUDE THAT THERE'S A
SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD THAT
THERE WAS A CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY
HERE AND IN FACT, ONE OTHER
POINT THAT NEEDS TO BE MADE
DURING THESE HEARINGS IS THAT IT
WASN'T JUST ABOUT THE JANUARY
6th VIOLENCE, IT WAS ABOUT THE
FAKE ELECTORS, ABOUT THE
PRESSURE ON PENCE, ABOUT THE
ATTEMPT TO COOPT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WE'LL HEAR FROM SOME
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
LAWYERS WHO DONALD TRUMP TRIED
TO PRESSURE.
ALL THOSE THINGS MADE THIS A
CONSPIRACY TO FRAUD THE UNITED
STATES, TO CORRUPTLY IMPEDE A
CONGRESSIONAL PROCEEDING, TO
FRAUDULENTLY ATTEMPT TO OBSTRUCT
GOVERNMENTAL FUNCTION, ALL OF
WHICH IS ILLEGAL UNDER FEDERAL
LAW AND EVEN WITHOUT THE
VIOLENCE, IT VIOLATED FEDERAL
LAW, BUT WITH THE VIOLENCE,
PUTTING IT ALL TOGETHER AND
HAVING ALL OF THESE STRANDS TIED
TOGETHER AND SHOW HOW THEY WERE
LINKED AND THEY WERE LINKED AT
THE TOP, BY ONE MAN, DONALD
TRUMP.
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO PUT THIS
ALL TOGETHER I THINK WOULD BE A
VERY CONSTRUCTIVE THING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SEE.
>> GEORGE, YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT
THE FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME, AS, YOU
KNOW, CNN REPORTING THAT IN THE
WAKE OF THE 2020, A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL CALLED GEORGIA
REPUBLICANS AND TOLD THEM TO
OPERATE IN, QUOTE, COMPLETE
SECRECY AND DISCRETION WHEN THEY
HELD THIS MEETING OF WOULD BE
ELECTORS.
COMPLETE SECRECY AND DISCRETION.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU?
>> WELL, THAT'S CLASSIC EVIDENCE
IN A CRIMINAL CONTEXT, IT'S
CLASSIC EVIDENCE OF CRIMINAL
INTENT, WHEN YOU ARE DOING
SOMETHING SURREPTITIOUSLY, TENDS
TO SUGGEST THERE'S A REASON YOU
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW WHICH
IS THAT YOU KNOW THAT WHOEVER
FINDS OUT ABOUT IT WOULD THINK
YOU ARE DOING SOMETHING WRONG
AND THEY WERE ACTING
SURREPTITIOUSLY, NOT BECAUSE, IF
THEY KNEW THAT SOMEBODY FOUND
OUT THEY WERE TRYING TO DO WHAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO, THEY
WOULD GET CALLED OUT FOR IT AND
PEOPLE OF THE GEORGIA CAPITOL
WOULD TRY TO STOP IT AND, YOU
KNOW, IT, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT EVIDENCE OF CRIMINAL
INTENT AND THE FACT THAT IT CAME
FROM THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS
HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT.
>> ALSO NOTABLE, THAT THIS
ELECTOR SITUATION IS PART OF THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION, PART
OF THE DOJ INVESTIGATION A